hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde Peyton spielt heute zum
allerersten Mal GTA ein ganz friedliches
Spiel dafür habe ich auch extra einen
Controller hier besorgt bzw ich besorgt
sondern einfach unten nach Schublade
gefunden der ist von 2015
ja also los geht's
was soll ich machen
ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung das hier
links das
hier ist das
viel Stolz
das ist auf jeden Fall dein Auto du
kannst jetzt den gelben Knopf drücken
genau perfekt und jetzt kannst du
einsteigen gib mal Gas
[Musik]
wir fahren jetzt einfach mal los und
Erkunden ein bisschen Los Angeles
genauso wie paid natürlich auch in echt
fährt meine Damen und Herren ganz
chillig die Harris direkt Schrott
schaffst du es bis ins Zentrum zu fahren
ohne eine Sache zu rammen ist doch schon
zu spät das stimmt hey das ist mir zu
kompliziert es ist überhaupt nicht
kompliziert es ist einfach
der Hund auch noch aber irgendwie habe
ich die Dings noch nicht so drauf die
Steuerung ja ich das auch ziemlich
kompliziert bin ich ganz ehrlich bei GTA
ist auch nicht so dass man irgendwie
gerade ich wollte überholen
GTA hat schon recht komplexe Steuerung
aber es ist halt auch ein sehr sehr
komplexes Spiel was halt fast schon seit
zehn Jahren draußen ist und die haben
immer noch nicht GTA 6 ansatzweise
vorgestellt oder was dazu gesagt also
dafür hey wie kannst du denn jedes Auto
mitnehmen was da irgendwie steht die
Steuerung nicht so drauf egal wir sind
jetzt auf jeden Fall in Downtown hier
vorne das ist doch nicht
Weg machst du das extra
warum fährt der von mir nicht weil rot
ist jetzt ist grün das heißt wir können
fahren Gas geben perfekt wir sind in ja
fahr mal rechts hoch wir sind in
Downtown meine lieben Freunde also in
l.a bzw GTA heißt das heißt die Stadt
nicht la sondern wollen wir hier stecken
suchen oder was
fahren wir einfach mal weiter geradeaus
genau da die Leitplanke noch mitnehmen
jetzt die von oh guck mal perfekt das
hat richtig gut guck mal ja
nicht runterfallen
ich kann das nicht so gut koordinieren
weiter geradeaus jetzt das war die
G-Klasse
links müssen wir eigentlich
wieder drehen sich denn
also bleibt sie stehen ich fahre jetzt
weiter nee ich links ab
rechts einordnen
und jetzt rechts abbiegen
perfekt guck mal da sind wir auf der
richtigen Straße was siehst du ganz am
Ende das Hollywood Sign perfekt genau
noch einen dicken Reiter geradeaus wir
sind jetzt hier gerade an der Ecke
hollywoodpboulevard ich komme jetzt
gleich ins etwas schönere Los Angeles zu
den schönen Häusern damals stehen mein
Auge
ich will los aber er fährt nicht Hupe
gibt's immer noch nicht oder
[Applaus]
okay Gas geben der hinter mir wollt mich
schon überholen okay wir fahren jetzt
mal weiter überhol den mal der nervt ja
ich hasse
weil man Stücken geradeaus erstmal noch
und gucken uns mal ein paar schöne
Häuser erstmal ein shoppen gehen wir
gleich da sind wir nämlich gerade dran
vorbeigefahren
ja okay dann fahren wir shoppen nee nee
nee fand doch nicht zurück lass mich
davon nee nicht wieder umdrehen dann
fahren wir doch nicht shoppen wir suchen
jetzt mal ein schönes Haus hier in GTA
Los Santos wo willst du denn gerne mal
hinziehen
in die Hills da sind wir
[Musik]
okay du fährst weiter also wir suchen
markiert du hast ja die komplette voll
hinter Schürze abgefahren ich habe
geschneit ist rein wie scheiße du
gefahren bist was wir fahren jetzt mal
an am Strand würde ich sagen und noch
weiter geradeaus guck mal hier überall
schön mit den mit den Palmen und so ne
Wahnsinn Alter geradeaus ich kann nicht
das in Autos
ich würde sagen wir nehmen anderes Auto
oh tötest du die Frau ein paar Sekunden
später
geschossen hätten mich weil Eiswagen
überfahren hast
du hast zwei Sterne von 5 das heißt ich
jagt jetzt die Polizei Fahrwerk ganz
schnell wir müssen uns jetzt ganz ganz
dringend verstecken ja so einfach fahren
das war schon wieder der Baum rückwärts
und das war das Schild und jetzt
vorwärts und Gas geben einfach los
einfach fahren einfach Baden war die
Straße runter
runterfahren genau sehr gut wir müssen
jetzt einfach vor der Polizei hören
linker Menschen by the way ähm wir
müssen jetzt nach rechts fahren wir
rechts
jetzt kannst du rechts perfekt also
jetzt rechts zur Spur wieder abbiegen
gib Gas gib Gas gib Gas geben
geil weiter geradeaus einfach runter zum
Meer links links links links links links
das meinte ich nicht weil wir die Straße
weiter entlang okay alles easy da rein
alles gut unten jetzt bitte links
abbiegen links abbiegen um die Kurve das
ist
nicht links scheiße ich muss falsche
Richtung
sehr gut weiter rechts weiter rechts wir
sind am Strand weiter links links links
links links und jetzt gerade aus ja wir
verstecken uns unter den äh dem Tier
das ist sehr gut glaube ich ja also die
suchen uns auf jeden Fall steht auf der
Karte
und ich glaube wir sind safe ja wir
haben es geschafft wir fahren jetzt mal
in Richtung skaterparadies oh cool boah
diese Spiele wirklich sowas finden echt
nur Typen nice ich kann kein Mädchen der
Sonne was für eine Scheiße spielt guck
mal du bist ja ein Los Angeles gerade ja
super wo sind die Skater
vielleicht in der Schule
wir sind aber nur hier um die Skater zu
sehen oder kannst du nicht selber skaten
[Musik]
ja das chillig wir können uns mehr gehen
schwimmen
warum gehe ich jetzt schwimmen keine
Ahnung
ich habe da immer noch Menschen getötet
ich meine in echt achso ja da auch
ich bin das alles schon einmal gefahren
nee du machst ja wieder weg okay wir
steigen einmal meine Damen und Herren
einmal kurz die Treppe da vorne hoch
hier den Schaffner kommen wir brauchen
keinen Ticket und dann wäre das Safe
drücke Fahrt kostet 8 $
habe 8 Dollar guck mal passend zum
Abschluss des heutigen Videos meine
Damen und Herren fahren wir eine Runde
Riesenrad wunderschöne Ausblick hier
hinten Golden Gate Bridge rechts
Köln-Bonn Airport ja
wundervoll du sollst Reiseführer werden
auch richtig schöner Sonnenuntergang den
wir hier sehen der ist wirklich schön
der geht wirklich klar ja was haben wir
hier Downtown die Links haben wir die
Hills hier das Riesenrad und ich würde
sagen mit diesem wunderschönen
Sonnenuntergang meine lieben Freunde
beenden weil dann jetzt auch das heutige
Video wenn es euch gefallen hat wie paid
zum allerersten Mal GTA V gespielt hat
dann lasst doch gerne einen Daumen hoch
da abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke um auch weitere Videos auf
meinem Kanal zu verpassen welche Spiel
soll PayPal als nächstes spielen
schreibt uns gerne unten in die
Kommentare du hast die letzten zehn
Worte um den 10.10 sind viel zu viel ich
habe jetzt zehn